hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show here's what's making the news today
farming for nature farmers in England
will now be paid for being more
environmentally friendly under new
government plans
new analysis suggests the UK's electric
vehicle charge point target is 20 years
behind schedule
and environmentalists criticize the
Kenyan government's methods for killing
up to 6 million Birds responsible for
eating over 300 acres of crops
foreign
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
now land openers and Farmers across
England will now be paid public money
for protecting the environment and
producing food more sustainably new
government subsidies give Farmers
bonuses for implementing environmentally
friendly agricultural practices like
managing crop pests without chemicals
and working towards net zero the
environment secretary Therese Coffey
said the new scheme would protect the
planet and help produce food in a less
environmentally damaging way
I'm really pleased that the sustainable
farming initiative where we've had three
ways to access in the last year we're
opening up now further six ways and we
focused on them in particular because we
want to be able to hit our environmental
and carbon targets so we prioritized
aspects that most farmers can get
involved in so whether that's about
um things to do with nutrient management
that building on the soil Health as well
as support particularly for Upland
Farmers that we've brought forward
recognizing that we want to help farmers
writer across the country as we move
this away from this basic payment system
to them paying them to help us not only
produce food sustainably but also to
help us improve the environment and
Achieve Net Zero well let's speak now to
the nature friendly farming networks
chair Martin lines to get his views on
all of this and welcome to you Martin
there were concerns weren't there that
nature policies might be stripped out of
the government's plans but in fact
farmers are going to be able to receive
Government funding for up to 280
different actions that protect the
environment so do you welcome that yeah
really welcome there has been huge
concern uh over the last few months
about where government policy was going
but these actions actually will help
farmers farming a more nature-friendly
farming way and do actions across a farm
landscape that will be rewarded by
public money in in that action that
costs businesses to deliver so it's a
real positive step forward well yes and
let's look at one example in particular
farmers are going to be encouraged to
use predatory bugs rather than
pesticides for example so how much do
you think that the incentives will make
a difference how much will it change
Behavior do you think I think once
Farmers understand it and get get the
behind what the government is asking
them to do I think they will really uh
intentionally be incentivized to do that
on our own Farm we're putting flower
strips around the outside of fields and
across the middle of the fields to
deliver that predatory insects and the
pollinators and we're seeing real
positive results from that so it's about
how the farming industry can step up and
communicate to other Farmers that you
know we're going to get rewards for
delivering this but it also has positive
benefits for our farming but you know
and farming and food production and it's
about how do we have the win wins
through delivering environmental
improvements moving away from those
harmful insecticides and working with
nature across our farm landscapes well
yes and you mentioned food production
how important is it that there is a
balance between protecting the
environment and making sure that we have
food security and increased food
production does do these plans keep that
balance in place yeah I think it's it
it's a fair balance could go further you
know keep pushing government to make it
go a bit further but actually a lot of
what we produce as Farmers isn't really
food that consumers eat it we produce a
range of goods and assets and nature and
climate mitigation must be front and
center alongside food production and if
we get the the environment right and our
climate mitigation right we'll have food
Security in the future and if we don't
address the challenges we have as a
society for climate and nature that's
where food production and food Security
will really be at risk so these schemes
and options will really help farming
industry move in or hopefully a more
positive direction and I urge all
Farmers to get involved because there's
some really good values of payments for
some of those outcomes there's also a
landscape recovery plan isn't there that
would encourage Farmers to work together
to rebuild an entire landscape whether
that's a salt marsh or an ancient
woodland or a wetland for example there
are some that are worried that that
isn't farming they think that should be
privately funded for example they think
that the money should go towards
sustainable farming instead what's your
view on that no um we've seen the last
round of applications loads of farmers
getting involved in working it at a
landscape scale delivering changes to
that landscape alongside food production
it's just a matter of where we set the
the ability to produce things in the
landscape some bits will be highly
productive for food others can have that
nature recovery and that landscape
approach for flood mitigation tree
planting and other things farmers manage
70 of our landscape of the UK so farmers
will be helped to deliver that and we
have the opportunity of delivering a
really multifunctional land use
delivering solutions that Society needs
in a changing climate and a changing
land Escape okay Martin lines very
interesting to get your take on it
thanks very much indeed now here are
some of the other stories making the
news today and the government is set to
miss its Target of installing 300 000
new electric charges by 2030 by 20 years
according to opposition leaders new
analysis has found that there are now 30
electric vehicles for every charge Point
fueling fears that infrastructure is
falling behind demand labor accused the
government of being asleep at the wheel
after fewer than 9 000 public electric
charging points were installed last year
the government said it spent more than
two billion pounds to accelerate the
transition to Electric
environmental Lobby groups in Kenya have
criticized Plans by its government to
kill up to 6 million red-billed quilia
birds in response to the decimation of
the country's rice crops the ongoing
drought has forced the red build qualia
Birds to feed on the crops destroying
300 acres already in 2021 crop losses to
the bird amounted to 50 million dollars
Farmers have now been authorized to
spray a toxic pesticide to kill the
birds however environmental Lobby groups
say this will have adverse effects on
the environment
it is unfortunate that their species has
already been considered as a pest within
our within our within our law
however
area poisoning of this blood is a bigger
danger in the ecosystem because this
would kill other species which are not
targeted in this in this control and
this by itself which increases the risk
of environmental contamination which is
a danger to us and a danger to the
entire ecosystem
green claims made about household
essentials like food drink and
toiletries are to be investigated to
make sure Shoppers aren't being misled
the competition and markets Authority
says it's concerned that Shoppers are
paying more for products that aren't as
they seem and is part of a wider
investigation into green washing the CMA
will analyze environmental claims made
about products such as their
sustainability and how recyclable they
are
the United States federal government has
announced its reinstating restrictions
on road building and logging in the
country's largest rainforest in Alaska
the U.S department of Agriculture
finalized plans to repeal a trump
Administration era decision that
Exempted the tongas from the so-called
roadless rule it's a huge boost for the
rainforest which provides habitat for
wildlife including Bears wolves bald
eagles and salmon
and before we go we want your climate
questions anything that's ever mystified
you about the environment or whatever
you want to get to the bottom of if you
scan the QR code on your screen right
now you can send us your questions which
will be answered in the climate Show
with Tom Heath
and you'll be able to watch Tom's show
on Saturday and Sunday at 3 30 here on
Sky News and this week he's talking
rubbish and why leaky landfills might
lead to more of it clogging our rivers
and oceans
but that's it from us for today do join
us again on the daily climate show at 3
30 tomorrow
[Music]